we're joined now by the cdc director dr
rochelle walensky dr wolinski good
morning thanks for being with us
good morning thanks for having me uh
just last month the cdc and the fda both
said we would not need booster shots
what specifically has changed in the
data that has changed your guidance
right several things so first in the
last six weeks we have seen delta in
this country we've seen increased number
of cases we now have over 98 of our
circulating virus be delta and just in
the last week we have started to see
evidence from numerous cohorts published
yesterday in our mmwr several different
studies
in different populations that have
started to show waning of vaccine
effectiveness against infection not
necessarily against severe disease yet
but against infection and so in our
process to stay ahead of this virus
we're starting to see it an infection
we're concerned we will see it in
in severe disease and we're planning
ahead to stay ahead all right as we just
heard in in ouija zhang's report uh dr
celine gander who was on the white house
coveted advisory task force
disagrees what do you say to her
so we have several studies that have
demonstrated waning effectiveness in 10
million people in new york state and 80
000 people in the mayo clinic and as
well in the delta variant
in in health care workers we've also
been in collaboration and discussions
with our international colleagues and
they are starting to see
worsening of present presentation of
worsening infection in the context of
their breakthroughs and so our plan now
is to get ahead of that we don't want to
start to see that in this country which
is why we're planning now for late
september after we hear from the fda and
the advisory committee on immunization
practices to be able to boost how soon
do you think the fda is going to act on
this
we're planning for late september and
we've been in discussions with the fda
and with acip and we think that that's a
very reasonable timeline and a timeline
which we believe to be reasonable to
protect americans who've been vaccinated
against severe disease if you if you've
had uh the shot the vaccination eight
months out will you be able to get a
booster in september
that's the vision in the plan that's
exactly what we're planning for right
now we have enough vaccine here to be
able to boost but also i want to
emphasize for the 100 million americans
who have not yet been vaccinated we will
have enough vaccine for you please go
get vaccinated because today you remain
at risk of severe disease dr wolenski do
you have a sense of when the data will
be in on the johnson and johnson vaccine
and whether those people who got that
vaccine will also need a booster
we anticipate that people who got
johnson and johnson will also need a
booster i want to remind people that we
that we started using johnson and
johnson more than two months after our
mrna vaccines so we're getting more
information that information is a little
bit delayed because we started using it
a little bit later do you also
anticipate and at least for the at the
very least cannot rule out at this stage
that we could end up getting an annual
booster shot much like the flu shot
um you know this virus has been humbling
so i i don't want to say never but um we
are not necessarily anticipating that
you will need this annually and it does
look like after this third dose you get
a really robust response and so we will
continue to follow the science both on
the vaccine side but also on the virus
side
all right that's certainly a little bit
of good news there possibly at the end
dr wolinski we appreciate you being on
thank you very much